>>Scott Morrison: Hi, everyone.
I'm Scott Morrison.
I'm the President of the MIT Club of New York.
And to begin with, I'd like to thank Stu and
also Graham Wharton from Google, who helped
us make the arrangements for this facility
tonight, and for all of the networking activity
and so forth.
So, could I have a round of applause please
for Stu and Graham?
[applause]
Thanks.
So, to continue with tonight's program, I'd
just like to introduce our speakers.
First, Cecilia D'Oliveira served as Technology
Director for MIT's OpenCourseWare since 2002
and was responsible for planning and support
of the initiative's technical infrastructure,
including software, hardware, networks and
technical standards used in the production
and delivery of MIT course materials to users
around the world.
She was named Executive Director of OCW in
September of 2008, with responsibility for
overall online courseware leadership.
Prior to her work with OCW, she co-founded
and served as Vice President of Operations
for SupplyWorks, a service provider for internet-based
manufacturing and procurement.
And before that, she spent 13 years in a variety
of technology leadership positions at MIT,
including Director of Information Technology
Support and Director of Distributive Computing
and Network Services.
She is an MIT alum, Bachelor of Science in
Computer Science and Engineering, Class of
'77, and Master of Science in Management,
Class of '79.
And then, I would like to introduce Shigeru
Miyagawa.
He's been at MIT since 1991, where he is Professor
of Linguistics and holds the endowed chair
Kochi-Manjiro Professor of Japanese Language
and Culture.
He runs a laboratory that creates interactive
educational programs.
And in line with this, he's also Chair of
MIT OpenCourseWare's Faculty Advisory Committee.
One of his innovations that I was quite interested
in is JP NET, which actually pre-dated OpenCourseWare
and the entire MIT Japanese program on the
web.
It was one of the first online projects in
the world to place an entire academic program
on the internet.
This was done from 1993 to 1994.
He received his Ph.D. in Linguistics from
the University of Arizona in 1980 and a BA
from the International Christian University
in Tokyo in 1975.
Please join me in welcoming both of our speakers
this evening.
[applause]
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Thank you.
Thanks.
Thank you very much, Scott.
Shigeru and I talked about which one of us
would do the presentation and we could've
flipped a coin and he could've ended up up
here.
But I'm gonna do the presentation part of
tonight, which should take about 30 minutes,
if everything goes according to plan.
And then, we'll do a shared kind of Q and
A session, which we hope to leave you like,
30 minutes or something for--.
So, I'm sure you all have lots and lots of
questions.
And that'll be a lot more fun than sitting
there and listening to me.
Let me start, first of all, by thanking people
who helped make this event happen.
The MIT Club of New York folks, for example,
many of whom are in the audience here, Greg
Martin, from Google, who's in the club, Yu-Hui
Lin, Scott, who just introduced me and several
others.
And I'd like to thank the club very much for
hosting us here.
I also wanna thank Google.
This is an amazing facility.
This room itself is amazing, but I got a quick
tour from Greg beforehand and what a wonderful
place to work.
I'm very jealous.
And I'd like to thank Stu Feldman, who's back
there, for his nice introduction.
And the MIT staff who helped put it on, too.
Wherever you are, Yvonne, I hope you're up
here now.
And Tom.
So, and thank all of you who are here tonight.
We have an interesting mixed audience.
I wanna start by saying that if you're an
MIT alum, can you raise your hand so we see?
If you are a Google employee, could you raise
your hand?
So, there's some overlap there.
If you're an OCW donor, you don't have to
raise your hand, but you can if you want to.
[laughter]
Terrific.
Welcome all of you tonight and thank you for
being here.
So, what I wanted to do before I get into
my actual presentation, is start with my own
personal thoughts on why this is important,
why I think MIT's commitment to openness,
which has been expressed in a very specific
way through OpenCourseWare, is more important
than ever in terms of what's going on with
education.
And it's what makes my job at OpenCourseWare
so fulfilling.
And I'll start by just a couple of facts.
First thing is, worldwide demand for higher
education has been accelerating for the last
20 years.
Between 2001, when we announced OCW, and 2010,
enrollments in higher education grew by 60
percent, from about 100 million to about 160
million, driven largely by growth in the developing
world.
In China, for example, growth in higher education
has been in the neighborhood of about 20 percent
per year every year for the last decade.
Access, though, to quality higher education
is severely limited in developing countries
where we're seeing so much growth.
And India's a prime example of that.
I mean, of the population in India today,
there's 1.2 billion or something like that.
Half of them are under the age of 25.
And if you look into--.
You think about the economy in India, which
is growing, there's a lot of people in the
middle coming into the middle class.
But the universities there--the traditional
universities there--can only handle about
ten percent of the people who could potentially
go.
Many of those institutions are facing the
inability to teach subjects that people wanna
take 'cause they don't have qualified teachers.
Within the comparable universities in India
to MIT are the IITs, the Indian Institutes
of Technology.
Fantastic institutions that are spread across
the country.
Their acceptance rate is less than two percent.
MIT's acceptance rate is more like--.
What is it, Shigeru?
Six percent?
The Ivy's are six to eight percent.
And the pool that that is going against is
a pool of a half a million kids who have taken
the exam and passed it.
So, it's not just anybody.
It's these kids who have studied for a couple
of years and they take the exam.
And still, only two percent of them can get
into the best institutes.
So, what can we be doing to help all of these
capable young students get access to quality
education?
Even in the US today, where we have significant
access to education, we have to do things
better.
I mean, we know that the percentages of students
who are not graduating from college are amazingly
high.
And we have a severe and growing shortage
of students who are majoring in engineering
and other STEM fields.
And then finally, lifelong learning has become
something that's really important to all of
us.
And in mature economies, more important, certainly
essential, I would say.
Whether you're trying to maintain your skills,
you're trying to change careers, you're trying
to get back in the workforce after being unemployed,
you just want to explore new areas of interest.
Whatever it is, I mean, and I'll give you--.
We have a number of examples of folks who
are fairly well-known, who have used OpenCourseWare
to come back and study energy because it's
a hot field and they wanna know about it.
And the person I'm talking about is Bill Gates.
[laughter]
Most of the people in these situations don't
have the time to go back and get formal education.
So again, what can we do to better serve that
population?
These are some of the opportunities that we
have before us now where open sharing, I think,
can make a difference.
And this is what, to me, makes OCW such a
fulfilling project to be part of.
So, tonight what I wanna do is just review
with you OCW's first decade.
What are the major things we think we've accomplished?
And then, move into a little bit of an overview
of what's going on now in different places
to try to take, to go from open content to
what I'll call open learning, to actually
create quality online learning experiences
that are openly available to people at the
level of magnitude that OCW has been.
We're learning about what it's gonna take
to do that.
And that's quite exciting.
And then I'll close by talking about what
the future of open education is at MIT, at
least as far as we know today, including a
few words about the announcement about a month
ago about MITx and what OCW's plans are for
the next decade.
And as far as all that goes, Shigeru and I
had scheduled this event before the announcement.
And so, this wasn't intended to be like, some
big announcement about MITx today.
And we, in fact, are not really the MITx people
at MIT.
But we can tell you what we know and if you
have specific questions, we can figure out
how to answer those.
So, moving along quickly here, you're all
familiar with the idea that MIT came up with
back in the year 2000, and Shigeru was part
of a very small committee, that looked at
what MIT could do to put itself on the internet.
They concluded that doing some kind of an
MIT dot com was not the way to go.
That putting our courses online in a way that
would be consistent with MIT quality was just
too, it would be too expensive.
And at that point in time, we had no idea
how to do it.
But we did wanna have a presence on the net.
And so, the idea that they came up with was,
"Let's just give all the materials from our
existing courses away.
Let's not do anything special.
Let's just put them all up."
And that was the very simple idea.
But it was pretty revolutionary.
A lot of people felt as though it was crazy
for an academic institution to give away intellectual
assets.
But in fact, it's very consistent with what
the mission is of MIT.
And for those of you who are MIT grads, MIT's
mission has been consistent for the entire
time I've been there.
And that's been a number of years.
I have a lot of grey hair that I didn't have
when I first came to MIT.
But the mission is to advance knowledge and
to educate students to serve the nation in
the world.
And so, doing something like OpenCourseWare
is just absolutely consistent with the mission.
And I think the committee that came up with
the idea drew heavily on the MIT mission in
terms of the idea.
And as Susan Hockfield, our current President,
says, "OCW expresses MIT's goal of advancing
education through a global community."
And so, if we look at the goals of OCW, number
one it was to help educators and learners
by sharing our materials.
But the second thing was to encourage other
universities to do this.
Our idea at the beginning wasn't that people
would just take MIT courses and adopt them
everywhere.
I think some people initially had that misinterpretation
that somehow, we were trying to take over
the world of education by enforcing our approach.
But our idea was basically to set a model.
And the model would be based on this idea
of openness and advancement through sharing
of ideas, sharing of knowledge.
And what we didn't say at the time, but what
was certainly very much discussed behind the
scenes, was that by encouraging our faculty
to put their materials online, that it would--I
won't say force them--but it would encourage
them to take things and dust them off and
update them and make them look better because
it was gonna have their name on it.
So, you all know OCW doesn't provide online
courses.
We provide the material that comes out of
classes.
And that repository, if you want to think
of it as a virtual library of course materials,
has grown and grown and grown.
We have materials of all different types.
We started with largely tech/space content.
And over time, as it became clear that video
was really, really popular and helped people
really understand the content better, we've
put resources in to video lecture capture.
But we basically take whatever the faculty
gives us.
There's a lot of variety in the course materials
we provide.
Some courses have very little.
Some courses are extremely rich with material.
And that's really a function of several different
things.
Intellectual property issues is one of the
big things that we face.
If it's property that isn't owned by MIT or
the faculty member, we really can't publish
it.
But there are also faculty references that
come into play.
Some faculty want to publish everything.
Others don't.
And the type of course.
We found in the Humanities areas, it's very
difficult, especially in seminar-type courses,
to really put those online without any interaction.
The materials themselves really aren't that
useful.
But we do what we can do.
Everything's available and this is a critical
part of what we do.
We're not just putting stuff up for people
to look at for free.
We're putting it up with an open, what has
now become known as Creative Commons license,
which allows for the legal reuse, redistribution,
copying, basically do what you want, with
a few restrictions.
And one of the major ones is non-commercial.
We were one of the first major institutions
to adopt the Creative Commons license.
It's now widely used, not just in education,
but in a variety of fields.
So, we began publishing our courses in 2002.
As Stu said, this is an ongoing operation.
We have people that are back in the offices
as we speak, who are working on publishing
our next set of courses.
We now have 21 hundred courses online.
We have hundreds that we've taken offline
and archived.
And this is something that MIT has committed
to keep running into the future permanently.
OK.
The costs of OCW have always been an issue.
People have said, "How does MIT pay for this?"
The operation costs about four million dollars
a year.
It's paid for through these various revenue
streams--individual donors.
We have an amazing annual fund with the kind
of program where people make online donations.
Last year, we got nearly 25 hundred donations
that way.
And they range from a dollar a month to--.
Somebody actually did an online donation of
like, 50 thousand dollars one time.
That was pretty amazing.
We also have corporate sponsors.
We have foundations that give us money, typically
for projects to do enhancements to the site.
We have a small amount, we're trying to grow
this, of revenue from places like Amazon,
referrals, ad revenues, and that sort.
And then, MIT sort of makes up everything
else, which right now is about half of our
costs.
So, we have a global audience.
I think the MIT community continues to be
amazed at the numbers of people that come
to our website.
We're the most visited website at the institute.
We now have between 1.5 and 2 million visits
a month.
A lot of those are repeat visitors.
Probably about 50 percent of the people are
people coming back.
So, people are finding a lot of value.
Our traffic has grown year by year.
Last year, we reached almost 19 million in
visits total.
And as you can see from the chart up there,
there's an awful lot of traffic that comes
outside of North America.
The MIT traffic is a very small part of traffic
to our site.
Areas like East Asia, China, Korea, end up
being about 20 percent of our overall traffic.
That's been pretty consistent.
Now, these numbers don't include offline ways
that we distribute our content.
We have a mirror site program where we take
content and distribute it on hard drives.
We have about 300 sites around the world that
run OpenCourseWare on a local server that
way because of internet bandwidth issues.
We also have sites--translation sites--that
have translated our content in different languages.
They run their own servers.
They have their own users that come there.
Those aren't included in our numbers.
We also put our content up on places like
YouTube.
And thank you very much Google.
That has saved us a huge amount of money in
terms of bandwidth over the last few years.
That was--.
One of my major concerns as Technology Director
in 2005 was how are we gonna keep up with
all this video traffic?
And then YouTube came along.
And that was a wonderful solution.
Traffic through YouTube and iTunes and places
like that where we put our video is also not
included here in terms of visits.
So, this is a minimal picture in terms of
things.
As we added all this stuff up in terms of
who has access and how do they have access,
we think that between 2001 and the end of
2011, we got about 100 million people who
access the content and used it in one shape
or form or another.
And so at MIT, that is something that we are
truly humbled by and certainly never expected.
Now, the impact of OCW has been both in the
formal learning side of things--.
And what I mean by that is where you teachers
and students and maybe the teachers are using
the content to expand their own knowledge,
students are using some of OCW for supplementing
their courses.
In some cases, teachers adopt our materials
and integrate it in their class.
But a lot of times, they're just looking at
what we have and how we teach to let that
inform how they're gonna teach their course.
So, there's a wide variety of ways that informal
teaching and learning, OCW gets used.
What has been most amazing, though, in terms
of use, is the informal learning side of OCW.
We had no concept when we started the project
that this site would be as heavily used as
it is by people who aren't formally taking
a course anywhere.
These were just raw materials.
These weren't materials that were prepared
for online use.
And yet, people found value in them.
Forty-three percent of our users--the largest
segment of our user base--it turns out are
informal users.
Absolutely amazing.
And this is a statistic that has been replicated
as new OCW sites opened up at other schools,
which I'll talk about in a minute.
This is a statistic that's been replicated.
So, informal learning, there's a huge demand
out there.
And I think over the last ten years as the
internet has grown, people have become familiar
with things like Wikipedia.
It's just the first place people go for information.
And for lifelong learners, OCW kinds of scenarios
fit in very well.
So, one of our goals, I think I mentioned
early on, was that we would not be the only
institution adopting this idea of openness
and sharing.
And in fact, very quickly, we had institutions
that MIT had close relationships with that
came and said, "What are you doing?
How do you do it?
We wanna do this, too.
We think it's a great idea."
And we started working together and figuring
out how to do things better and sharing best
practices.
And this eventually turned into something
that we call the OCW Consortium.
It's an independent organization now-- its
own board of directors, its own staff.
It has about 250 member institutions that
pay dues.
And if you look across those sites, MIT was
the model, but we have sites doing all kinds
of different, really amazing things.
And there are about 15 thousand courses up
there in different languages.
One of the things Shigeru was very involved
in was one of the first regional consortiums
that set up schools within Japan, came together,
I don't know what year it was.
Maybe 2005, 2006.
Ten of the leading institutions there formed
a Japanese Consortium.
There's now regional OCW consortia in Korea
and Taiwan as well.
And the consortium has been great 'cause it's
provided a collaborative way for various schools
to get together and work on projects.
An example of that right now is happening
in Europe.
They have this thing called the Bologna Process,
where the EU is trying to integrate some of
the educational stuff going on in higher education.
And one of the things they're trying to do
is something called "student mobility," so
it's easier for students to move across borders
and from school to school.
A bunch of the OCW universities in Europe
have come together to try to figure out, "How
can we use our OCW curriculum to actually
make this happen?"
And that's a very exciting project.
Now, one of the things that happened along
the way.
We were doing OpenCourseWare and then, all
kinds of things started happening that we
didn't anticipate.
And we became the spark for something that
became known as the Open Educational Resources
movement.
This is a broader movement than OCW.
It includes organizations that aren't even
academic institutions.
It includes individuals.
It's a term that was first adopted in 2002
by UNESCO.
They held a forum to look at what the impact
of OpenCourseWare would be in higher education.
They came up with this term.
It includes all kinds of materials.
It includes software, services.
It includes things like the licensing framework
from Creative Commons.
And it has really been nurtured and grown
through the Hewlett Foundation, grants, and
targeted programs.
So, if you look at the OER Movement, I just
went out and collected a bunch of the logos
from some of the most well-known institutions
that are part of OER, and you'll see it includes
both educational institutions and it includes
some educational institutions that aren't
even part of the OCW Movement, formally, like
Yale and Stanford, where they're sharing stuff,
but they're really not part of the Consortium.
It includes groups that formed specifically
to translate the content.
It includes groups that have funded a lot
of this work.
It includes--.
Some are strictly policy-making institutions,
like UNESCO.
It includes some for-profit companies.
I mean, I consider YouTube and iTunes and
OpenStudy and Flat World, all of these for-profit
companies that are helping us make this movement
happen to be part of--and they're providing
free services to do it--they're part of the
movement.
There's NGOs like the African Health OER Network.
There are small entrepreneurial start-ups,
like Peer-to-Peer University.
And it goes on and on and on.
It's a very fertile time.
Within the US, a lot of this OER energy has
been focused on things like the cost of textbooks
and what can we do with open resources to
drive down the cost of textbooks?
And so, we have Flat World Knowledge and we
have an initiative in California to develop
free and open textbooks.
The State of Washington invested in the development
of 80 open courses, which are largely trying
to do away with textbooks.
And finally, in terms of the movement, there's
national governments like India, like the
Netherlands, like Korea, who are actually
incorporating the idea of open educational
resources in their national education policy.
So, we've accomplished a lot in the last ten
years.
I mean, if you step back and you look at where
we've been, we've helped millions and millions
of learners.
And as I said, in an environment where a large
portion of the world's population doesn't
have access to quality higher education, and
when lifelong learning has become in larger
and larger demand, OCW has been an answer
in some ways.
We've supported educators.
We've helped high school educators develop
better understanding of math.
We've helped other educators who are trying
to figure out, they've got to teach a course
for the first time, how should they do it?
This was our primary target and that is absolutely
one of the things that we have fulfilled.
We've supported flexible lifelong learning,
whether it's a working professional, it's
a non-traditional student like a homeschooler,
it's someone who has had a lot of trouble
working in a formal classroom, but finds it
a lot easier to work online at their own pace.
We've had entrepreneurs who are trying to
look for reference material.
One of my favorite cases is a guy from Haiti
who's developing some solar panels and needed
some information on integrated circuits.
And he didn't have a library in Haiti, but
he did have OpenCourseWare.
And the final two things.
I think we have created a model for government,
for institutions, for individuals in terms
of open sharing.
So much is underway.
And I've talked about a lot of that already,
so I won't go into that now.
And finally, and I think this is really where
we get most exciting, is that through having
open content out there, we've inspired a lot
of experiments in open education to try to
figure out how to take the content and turn
it into a quality online experience.
And we'll talk about some of these experiments
in a minute.
So, we've done this thing with OpenCourseWare.
It's been ten years.
So, what's the next big opportunity for open
education?
And I would say these projects, which I've
had to go through and pick out just a handful
of them that I could fit on a slide, these
projects are some of the projects I think
that have done the most to try to take open
content into open learning.
Khan Academy you're all familiar with.
Something that went online in 2006, is now
serving about four million visitors a month,
a couple thousand video tutorials, has really
established a model for how you can effectively
teach online in a modular kind of way.
Integrated exercises to help people check
whether or not they know what they're doing.
So, that's been an extremely interesting project
that we've been watching and I think we've
learned a lot from that about how you could
adapt content to make the whole experience
better.
The CMU Open Learning Initiative is another
amazing one, was founded actually in 2001,
right around the same time as OCW.
It's a group of learning scientists who work
with experts to put together online courses
that have been designed with all the best
learning in science.
It's expensive, but what they've done is modeled
for us how do you really create an effective
online experience, something that can be as
effective as in class.
And that means what we've learned from them
is assessment--continual assessment, continual
feedback--to people online is really important.
OpenStudy is a very small group that started
a couple years ago that is providing free
student study groups online where students
who maybe are using OpenCourseWare can ask
each other questions, answer other questions,
basically interact with people.
And they're experimenting with things like
badges to inspire people and to recognize
people for their contributions in an open
learning kind of environment.
We've hooked up a number of our courses to
OpenStudy.
Peer-to-Peer University is a bunch of people--volunteers--who
take open content and teach courses to anyone
who wants to take it.
And it's on a variety of topics.
A lot of them are web-based kinds of things.
But that's been interesting because it's really
peer-to-peer.
It's not necessarily expert-led.
What we've learned there is that moderated
peer groups can actually be quite effective
in learning.
They're doing a lot with badges right now
to try to figure out, again, how those can
be used to certify mastery in an online setting.
And then the final one I'll talk about briefly.
I'm sure most of you heard about the Stanford
courses that went online in the fall.
Yes?
Got announced [chuckles] last August or something
that they were gonna open up some courses
that they had been teaching at Stanford with
Stanford students.
They were gonna redesign them, open them up
for free online use to anybody who wanted.
They had 160 thousand people register for
the AI-Lab course, for the AI course, in a
very quick period of time--several weeks.
It turns out about 20 thousand students actually
finished that course successfully, from what
I understand.
And the most amazing thing is that there were
200 students in the course that scored perfectly
on the exams.
And I don't know if that includes the homework.
Whatever it was, 200 students had perfect
scores.
All of them were online learners, not the
students at Stanford who were taking the class
simultaneously.
That is amazing.
And I think what it is is a lot of the content
they have--short video tutorials online--students
can go back and do them again and again and
again, until they get it.
A Stanford student doesn't have time to do
that, I don't think.
So, what we learned is there's a huge interest
there for this kind of course, especially
when it's being taught by fairly well-known
experts in the field with a name like Stanford
associated with it.
We also learned that the, again, having the
ability to take tests and get your stuff graded
was really important.
And they got a certificate, although it wasn't
signed by Stanford, I don't think.
But I think people like that as well.
The only question I have about this is, and
I just need to have a conversation with folks
at Stanford to confirm this, it's a free course,
but it wasn't clear to me the content was
open.
It wasn't clear to me that people could take
the content, maybe put it on their own server,
teach their own course with it.
That would be the optimal.
That would be where we would like to have
things go.
But it was a fantastic effort.
So, finishing up here.
So, the question that I have before us now
is the issue of scaling.
Publishing of OpenCourseWare has been a very
scalable thing.
We take course materials from MIT.
We prep them for the web.
We put them online.
It costs us about ten to 15 thousand dollars.
Sounds like a lot, but when millions of people
use the resources, it's actually very cost
effective.
The problem is how do you teach and how do
you really get the learning to scale like
that?
Really, two questions.
How do you construct a quality online learning
experience?
And two, how do you scale it so the costs
don't just go out of the ceiling?
And what, I think, we found from these experiments
and others is that you need content design
for online.
You need it to be modular.
You need interactive resources.
In the case of the Open Learning Initiative
at CMU, they actually have an online tutor
that guides people, navigates them, gives
them frequent feedback.
Very helpful to learners online.
You wanna have interactive simulations.
You wanna have, from an MIT perspective, you
wanna have online labs.
The interactive components are really important.
And that also includes interactive online
communities.
That was one thing, I think, about the Stanford
Project that was really good.
They had all kinds of ways for people to interact
with each other and work through the material.
That'll be essential in building scaled learning
environments.
You need a delivery platform that's gonna
scale to millions, or at least to thousands
and hundreds of thousands of simultaneous
users.
And optimally, from a learner's point of view,
you wanna have some kind of credential that's
gonna recognize all the work they did.
So, where does that lead us to?
So, December 19th.
MIT announced something called MITx.
And the announcement said we're gonna offer
free online courses and make learning tools
freely available.
This is an initiative that's been under discussion
in different forms for a couple of years.
The announcement was made at the end of the
year for a number of different reasons.
Work is underway now.
There will be some initial pilot courses launched
this spring at some point.
The project is being led by our provost.
The development of the learning platform that's
gonna be part of this is being done by the
director of our Computer Science and Artificial
Intelligence Lab, Professor Agarwal.
Many of you know him.
The components of this that have been announced
are very much in line with what I went through
when I said, "What would it take to really
scale and create a quality online experience?"
It's gonna have self-paced materials, very
modularized.
There's gonna be interactivity built in, both
in terms of the learning resources as well
as a virtual community.
There's gonna be some automated assessment
of the work, so you don't have to have TAs
grade things.
You're gonna have automated ways of doing
that.
And it's gonna be based on an Open Source
platform.
And I think the idea here is to have a platform
that can be developed by people around the
world and enhanced in a continuous development
way.
Very much of an Open Source mentality.
And then the big thing was they're gonna offer
something that's called an MITx Certificate.
It won't be an MIT credit.
It won't be an MIT certificate.
But it will be something that is accredible,
verified in some way, certificate that says
you learned what the course taught or what
the subject taught.
So, the next decade, just to make clear, there's
gonna be three things going on at MIT.
They're education-focused at a global level.
There's regular MIT, selective admissions,
tuition, degrees, access to all of our wonderful
facilities.
Maybe we'll have online courses as part of
that.
We'll see.
Number two, OCW will continue as it is today,
which is providing MIT course materials openly
for people to use.
Free and open access.
Continuing to update.
And then finally, MITx, which is gonna be
really experimenting with what it means to
offer online courses for thousands of people
at a time, providing quality learning experiences.
So, those three things will exist going forward.
OCWs next decade I can talk about because
I'm responsible for that.
I'm not responsible for MITx.
And what I can tell you is we're gonna continue
to enhance our content.
Video is gonna become more and more of what
we do.
As faculty adopt different kinds of video
formats, those will be incorporated within
our publication.
We wanna grow our learning communities.
We have learning communities set up through
OpenStudy.
We wanna figure out ways to really grow those
and make those work.
We'll be sharing OCW more widely.
We've done it through YouTube and iTunes and
other places before.
We think there's a big opportunity, say, with
Wikipedia taking some of our content in short
form, integrating into Wikipedia articles
to get it out there.
We've gotta figure out what our mobile strategy
is.
And then, we'll continue to do what we've
done for the last several years, which is
targeting groups, user groups, within OCW
that we think are really important whether
it's high school students or teachers or self-learners
and trying to figure out how can we adapt
ever so slightly what we do to present the
materials in a way that's more accessible
and easy to use for those specific groups?
So, that's basically my presentation.
Let me close by saying that they say that
a journey of a thousand miles starts with
a single step.
And certainly with OCW, back in 2001, we took
a step.
And what we have been on is a journey that
had a lot of surprises along the way.
I don't think anybody here or at MIT could
have predicted what the impact was gonna be
of OpenCourseWare or where we would be now
in 2012, announcing an online course initiative.
With this announcement, I think we've started
a new journey in Open Sharing.
And so all I can say is stay tuned.
The adventure continues at MIT.
Thanks very much and let's have some questions.
[applause]
>>Graham Wharton: I'd like to start by asking
people if you do have questions to come to
the microphones.
There's one here and there's one on the other
side of the room.
And also, we have folks on video chat from
Irvine, from Mountain View, and from Cambridge,
I believe.
And so, if any of the folks on video chat--you
probably hear me right now--if you could please
jump in between questions.
And hopefully, you'll be acknowledged.
I want to start off the questions by saying,
well, a hundred million is pretty good and
repeats.
And you're probably closer to a billion now
by having courses translated to Spanish and
Chinese, perhaps.
I wanted to ask how close are you actually
already to the goal of one billion and what
will it take to get there?
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: No, no, no, Graham.
No.
We're at the hundred million level.
I mean, can we reach a billion?
There's seven billion people in the world.
What percentage of them can benefit from MIT?
Maybe, I don't know, 500 million?
I don't know a billion.
That's out there really for impact more than
anything.
But Shigeru, do you think we can get to a
billion?
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Well, maybe with the help
from other people.
One thing that you mentioned that's important
is that we have the original CourseWare in
English.
That's what MIT offers.
But we also have translation sites in Spanish,
Portuguese, Chinese, what else?
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Turkish.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Turkish.
Thai.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Persian.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: And those sites get a
fairly large number of access as well.
And we hope to grow that to other languages.
But our hope, right now, we have a hundred
million people who have used OpenCourseWare
in the past ten years, which, by the way,
for those of us who are in the original committee,
we had absolutely no idea.
Absolutely no idea that it would be this big
a thing.
But our hope is to go from a hundred million
to a billion.
And to go from here to there, very clearly,
we need to collaborate with other people,
hopefully such as Google to help us to get
there.
>>MALE #1: Hand editing things like Wikipedia
is one way to get things, but to have things
found more easily, particularly since you've
got so many institutions, some sort of metadata
would be very helpful for finding it.
Are you developing some sort of standards
for the metadata so people can find and put
together parts of a program that makes sense
for them across multiple institutions?
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Well, it's a really
good question.
We've done very rudimentary things.
I mean, certainly with OpenCourseWare at MIT
we have lots of metadata on our courses, down
to the resource level.
We've worked at the consortium level on some
search tools.
So, if you go to the OCW Consortium site,
there's actually a search place where you
can search for courses across all of the institutions.
And those work marginally well.
I mean, what we're dealing with is a bunch
of academic institutions that don't have a
lot of resources.
And we would love to have people who are experts
help us with this problem.
We do the best we can do.
So, but it's a big issue.
Even just on the OpenCourseWare site at MIT
alone, I'd love to have help on our search.
>>MALE #2: Quick question.
Could you give me the website for your Japanese
material?
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Ah.
It's, well, you can go to OCW.
It's O-C-W dot M-I-T dot E-D-U.
That's the general site.
And on the left side, you will see different
schools.
And my materials are under School of Humanities,
Arts, and Social Science.
And if you go to foreign languages section,
you will find Japanese and Chinese and Spanish
and so forth.
>>MALE #2: OK.
Now, the key one was O-C-W dot M-I-T dot slash--.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Dot E-D-U.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Dot E-D-U.
>>Graham Wharton: Chances are Google will
find it.
[laughter]
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Type in OpenCourseWare
Japanese, and it'll probably lead you there.
>>Shigeru: There we go; there we go.
>>MALE #3: So, when we're talking about a
formal course of study, you earn a degree
or you earn in this case, let's say MIT has
a certain certificate of accomplishment.
And that has a very clean delineation, demarcation
of learning.
In the case of, as you said, the plurality
of users are self-learners, what metric are
you using to define learning?
Maybe you could elaborate on that and how
you might be able to use that as a way of,
shall we say, tuning the output from OCW ON,
and the more general OER space.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: That's a great question.
And really, I mean, we have--.
Our evaluation program includes three different
pieces.
I mean, there's our web analytics, which is
what gives you the gross numbers of where
people are coming from and how many visits
a month and all that.
We also do, on a regular basis, surveys of
different target populations.
We always do some kind of major user survey
every year.
And through those surveys, we find out who
people are and how they're using the material.
And we typically go into that with a very
constructed kind of evaluation tool to get
at how are they using it, what were the outcomes,
and that sort of thing.
It ends up that we publish that data.
It's not like we have a before and after case
that we can build that says "this person started
here, they did OCW, and this is where they
ended up."
That's just a limitation of being in the kind
of world that we're in.
I think MITx is gonna be able to do a heck
of a lot more because you'll be able to evaluate
students on the way in and you'll be able
to evaluate students on the way out.
Give you a lot more real learning data.
But we try to do what we do with surveys and
then we actually go out we interview.
We do interviews, in-depth interviews, with
a select number of people.
And those end up being more like case studies.
>>MALE #3: OK.
So, just generally though, based off of the
surveys and the feedback that you received,
of let's say the 43 percent of people who
are self-learners, what proportion of them
are, shall we say, developing comprehension
as opposed to just looking up information?
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: A lot of it is reference
uses.
I mean, people who are working professionals,
the typical thing there is they're trying
to enhance their skill in a particular area.
They come to the site.
They look for a specific kind of course.
They pick through it and they figure out,
"OK.
Here's the couple things I wanna learn."
They don't necessarily come and go through
an entire course.
I mean, self-learners are all over the place,
too.
We also have self-learners who I would say,
a typical high school student, who may not
have access to AP Physics in the high school
they're in, but they wanna take it.
And their teacher says, "Hey, Walter Lewin
teaches a wonderful course on OpenCourseWare.
Just go watch his videos."
And we've had people who've said they did
that.
They aced their physics course.
They aced their SAT subject tests and they
came to MIT.
So, it's a whole range of things.
I don't think--.
That's about all I can say.
>>MALE #3: Well, thank you.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Yeah.
>>MALE #4: Hi.
So, clearly OCW has had a lot of really great
impact on a lot of students out there who
are trying to learn things or people who are
just trying to better teach things.
Could you maybe talk a little bit about what
impact OCW has had on MIT?
And whether OCW is doing or could be doing
anything to give back to the professors who
are contributing content and the MIT community?
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Yes.
Thank you.
So, when we first proposed OCW, we had in
mind the rest of the world.
And we did not really think about how it might
impact the institutes in education.
But as we got into this, within just a few
years we realized that there's a whole set
of benefits that we get.
So, for example, right now, about 90 percent
of our students, MIT students, use OCW.
How are they using it?
Well, they're using it not only for their
own course, but they're looking at OCW sites
of courses that they might want to take a
look at to take.
Professors are using the OCW site to advise
students on courses that they might want to
take.
Eighty-four percent of faculty members are
using OCW.
And how are they using that?
Of course, they look at their own site, but
what's really remarkable to me is that those
professors tell us that they are looking at
other professor's OCW sites and they want
to see how they're teaching.
But there's something actually quite, quite
important and profound about this.
And this is a point that I make when we talk
about benefit to MIT.
As faculty members, typically, and this is
true all over the world, once you start teaching,
you rarely get to see other people teaching.
So, you have your own model.
But you don't see many, many models.
But with OCW, all of a sudden, you get to
see a hundred different models.
So, this is really helping the quality of
education.
A third benefit is that we ask our freshman
if they are looking at OCW when they were
in high school and roughly half said that
they were, which we are very happy about.
But what was surprising to us was that of
those who were looking at OCW in high school,
something like 36 percent told us that OCW
was a significant factor in school choice.
And as you know, students who get into MIT
also get into other schools and of course,
the primary reason is that they want to study
computer science and biology and so forth.
But OCW played a significant role in school
choice.
>>MALE #4: Thank you.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Can I just add quickly
that alumni make a large use of our site,
too?
So,--.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Fifty percent of alumni
look at OCW site.
>>MALE #5: Hi, I'm a proud OCW participant.
I'm taking a course right now in computer
science with you guys.
So, thank you.
I actually wanted to start with a quick quote
from Kevin Kelly.
He was a co-founder of Wired Magazine.
And in his book, "What Technology Wants,"
he was actually writing about e-readers.
But he wrote, "When we think about new technologies,
our immediate tendency is to imagine the new
thing doing an old job better.
That's why the first cars were called horseless
carriages.
The first movies were simply straight-forward
documentary films of theatrical plays.
And it took a long time to realize the full
dimensions of cinema photography as its own
new medium that could achieve new things,
reveal new perspectives, do new jobs."
And I think that the, it seems like the first
phase of OpenCourseWare, where we're simply
putting the lectures online and allow people
to come and enjoy them, much as they would
in a traditional environment, is almost like
that horseless carriage phase.
It's very exciting to see things move into
this new phase where MITx is going to be offering
its new courses online.
I work at a company called Knewton and we
do adaptive learning technologies.
So, these are basically a way to take any
kind of content, whether you're a textbook
publisher, professor, etcetera, and drive
that content adaptively sot that no one student's
path through a course is the same as any others.
And the exciting thing about this actually
is that eventually it will allow us and other
companies that are doing similar things to
what we're doing to have access to these huge
reams of data on how students progress through
the course, how they learn best.
And so, I was just curious, especially looking
forward to MITx, whether you're planning to
use adaptive learning technologies and also
what implications you see for once you're
collecting this data on students and when
you have millions of people around the world
taking MITx courses, if that's going to be
something that you're gonna be looking at
as a way to improve them, a way to uncover
new ways of teaching, etcetera?
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: I will say that there
are several faculty members who are involved
in the MITx initiative that just get deliriously
happy for the reason that you just pointed
out, which is access to data about what really
helps people learn.
We have a professor in physics, Dave Pritchard,
who's been teaching a freshman physics course
for several years.
And he actually is into this whole adaptive
assessment kind of piece.
He has his own software.
He developed something called Mastering Physics,
which Pearson actually picked up and it's
used by hundreds of thousands of people, which
does a lot of data collection and some amount
of adaptive stuff.
Dave is now working on another generation
of that and he's very--.
I mention the Carnegie Mellon project, the
OLI Project, that does a lot of this adaptive
stuff and Dave works very closely with them.
So, I think that's a kind of thing that you'll
see over the next few years, get integrated
in here.
And yes, I agree with you about the--what
did we do?--this is first generation.
OCW shows how MIT has taught.
As teaching at MIT evolves through online
technologies, it will look different.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Can I just add to that?
OCW is a way of doing something new with something
old.
But there's something very profound about
OCW.
And that is that OCW's mission is really MIT's
mission.
And OCW has allowed us to express that mission
of the institute in a new way.
If you go to the website, it says that MIT's
mission is to create, to preserve, and disseminate
knowledge and to bring that knowledge to bear
on the great problems of the world.
So, MIT has been known for basic research
in expressing that.
But now with OCW, we get to do that with education.
And I think that's something that's really
important.
And that's why it's been so successful at
MIT because it is a core value that we have
been able to express with OCW.
>>MALE #5: Thank you.
>>FEMALE #1: Hi, my name is Diane Liebowitz.
I graduated from MIT as an undergraduate.
And just looking at MITx, something immediately
came to mind.
One of the biggest problems that we deal with
now is unemployment.
And a lot of that is in finance and a lot
of is because certain roles simply don't exist
anymore.
Mortgage-backed securities immediately come
to mind.
And so, there are a lot of very bright people
out there in finance, many of them MIT graduates,
who are in this situation and one of the ways
you deal with a situation like this if your
role isn't so prominent anymore because of
the changing environment is to adapt your
skill set.
And what I'm seeing is that a lot of what
you do in order to adapt the skill set is
learning new things, all of which have some
certification attached to them: C++ certification,
SAS certification, Project Management certification.
And let's say, to get one of these certifications,
all you need to do is just sign up for NYU
Continuing Education, pay five or six thousand
dollars, and take a series of courses and
you're certified.
So, the first thing I thought of when I saw
MITx was, "Has any consideration been given
to, let's say, somebody wants to get C++ certification
while they're not working.
And really spend some productive time building
on their skill set without having to spend
five or ten thousand dollars to do that, rather
than getting this official, very costly certification
to get, let's say, an MITx certification?"
It essentially means the same thing.
The certification means you know the material,
which is what people really wanna hear.
So, has there been any thought to maybe looking
into the types of things that people in the
real world are out there trying to learn who
would need this certification to really adapt
their skill set?
Because the world is crawling with quants
right now and it's very tough to compete.
And one way to compete is to learn some of
these skills if you're coming from finance,
some of the more technical skills that you
might not have needed before.
Because what you were doing before, let's
say, was very proprietary.
But now you need C or SAS or MatLab or whatever.
Has any thought been given to addressing that
population?
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Shigeru, do you have
any insight to that?
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: You're hitting at exactly
why we have to do this open learning.
Open learning is exactly what you see, what
Stanford did with the AI course and what we
intend to do with MITx.
And that is that, I mean, exactly what you
said, that skill sets are changing and they
change, according to some people, every five
years.
You have to reboot.
Now, every five years you cannot go back to
school because you are out there in society.
And so, there has to be a way to reboot and
to learn new things.
And open learning is, I believe, the way to
do it.
And this is why it's going to be critical
that we provide the kinds of education that
we see.
Now, MIT offers a certain kind of education,
right?
MIT's known for its science and engineering--the
STEM courses.
And those are the courses that I would imagine
that MITx is going to focus on.
We offer what we do best.
Other schools will offer other skill sets,
but absolutely.
This is going to be essential, critical to
our future in terms of the labor force and
the wealth of the country.
>>FEMALE #1: OK.
Great.
Thank you.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: Hi. Andrew Bein,
Class of '87.
This has been great and the benefits are very
clear.
I'd be very curious to hear if there had been
discovered costs, especially with a third
new way of educating coming and what costs
have occurred and been anticipated, not in
dollar, but in terms of education.
I'll give you an example.
If you're in classroom where there's a video
on, it's a different classroom experience
than if you're just there with your fellow
students and a professor.
Maybe a better experience, I'm not sure.
But are there scenarios that you've looked
at and policies you've developed to deal with
conflicts among the three different ways of
providing courses?
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Well, within OCW I
can speak that we don't bring cameras into
a classroom if it's gonna disrupt the learning
experience there.
We tend to--.
There are a lot of classrooms at MIT now that
have cameras that are built-in, just like
this room has cameras that are built-in and
you just don't notice it.
So, that's why for seminars, it's really hard
'cause we're not gonna bring a camera into
a seminar 'cause it's gonna create an artificial
situation.
So, just to answer that specific question.
Are there other costs?
We try to minimize faculty time.
I mean, we try to keep faculty time to four
or five hours for an OCW course.
We do all the work.
That's why we cost four million dollars a
year.
So, we've tried to avoid the impact on the
existing MIT educational program.
>>MALE #7: To what extent could MITx or OCW
actually be used as a platform for innovation,
with the possibility of self-learners contributing
back and perhaps solving some of the problems
that even MIT hasn't solved yet?
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: I think that's yet
to be seen.
MITx--.
We'll have to see how that evolves and how
broad and sweeping the goals are.
I do believe that you're gonna see much more
of a focus on community contribution and community
participation than we've been able to deliver
in OpenCourseWare.
I mean, there's a lot of resources that are
gonna be put into the development side of
MITx to create the kind of platforms that
would allow that kind of interactivity.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Yeah.
We're seeing a little bit of it in OpenCourseWare
already.
So, I was talking to professor in Chemical
Engineering who had launched a new course.
And he needed some pieces of programming.
And he went on OpenCourseWare and found what
he needed under the professor's site.
And so, he got that and got the approval and
used it.
So, there are things like this happening.
We don't get to document it.
But OCW does have that kind of dynamic built
into it as well.
>>FEMALE #2: Hi.
I was wondering what sorts of things are decided
within the coalition--the OCW coalition--
and how you get decision-making to take place
and if there's anybody who has any kind of
authority over or if it's just group decisions?
I'm just curious about that part.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: It's a very loose
consortium.
I mean, there's a board of directors, but
the board of directors is really responsible
to the membership.
It's a membership organization.
There are projects that get spawned.
There will be some interest group in metadata,
for example.
And you'll bring together technical people
from around the consortium and they might
come up with a standard.
We had a group that got together several years
ago to look at best practices in what's called
Fair Use under copyright law and to actually
write a document together that tried to articulate
policy--.
Not policy-level, but what our practices would
be in terms of using Fair Use in our content.
But there's no, it's not like a group that
has any power over any of the institutions.
It's really a membership organization designed
to help the members on whatever the problems
are that they have in common.
>>MALE #8: So, I apologize for what might
be a naive question, but when I think of things
like OpenCourseWare and the OER initiatives,
I naturally think of the impact it would have
on the cost of tuition.
So, there's been a lot of talk lately about
increasing cost of tuition, bubbles in tuition,
things like that.
I'm curious if you can talk about how you
think the various initiatives, OER, OCW, as
well as MITx, could potentially impact that
in the long term.
Is it, yes it could impact it in a very dangerous
way, like really affecting tuitions?
Maybe it'll bring it down a little bit, but
not significantly?
Or, they are two completely different things.
MITx is really addressing people, trying to
do continuing education, and things like that.
And existing tuition policies are a completely
different bucket and there's no reason to
worry about the two interacting.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Ooh.
That's a hard question.
I can tell you that in the discussions that
I've heard at MIT about why are we doing MITx,
I've never heard someone say, "We're doing
it because we've gotta deliver education more
cheaply."
[chuckles] That hasn't been part of the whole
equation.
It's been, "Can we scale it to like, a lot
of people?"
It's been, "Can we figure out how to teach
online effectively so that we can improve
our own educational programs and give our
students more flexibility?"
As an engineer at MIT, as a student at MIT,
it's really hard to go away for a semester
and study someplace else because we don't
have online capabilities.
That means when you go, you can't take MIT
courses.
[chuckles] And that's hard and it really messes
up your whole degree path.
So, that's one.
I think that's some of the thinking in terms
of MITx is we've gotta figure out how to do
online education at MIT for MIT students,
so that we can improve our educational program.
But it's not to make it cheaper to do.
Now, there may be things that come around
that it's gonna be less expensive.
Now, OER on the other hand, look outside the
broader world, OER certainly is being used
to try to reduce the cost of textbooks.
I mean, textbooks is a huge issue.
Cost of textbooks in community colleges, pretty
much every community college that I have sampled,
the textbook cost is at least 50 percent of
the total cost of education.
In California, it's more than the cost of
tuition.
So, the textbooks, I think, there's a lot
of opportunity to drive costs way down.
For our educational programs, I haven't heard
the discussions along those lines.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: See, one thing to keep
in mind is that MIT, like many Ivy schools,
have a need blind policy, which means that
a student that's accepted at MIT and then
once the decision is made, then we take a
look at the financial needs of the student
and we give that student whatever he or she
needs to come to MIT.
And so, yes, the tuition is expensive, but
we try to help out.
Now, if something like MITx or some other
effort can bring us extra revenue to MIT,
then that could be turned into more financial
aid for students who need it so that we can
give opportunity as wide an array of students
as possible to come to MIT.
>>MALE #8: Thank you.
>>MALE #9: Hello.
My name is Jay Damask.
I'm Class of '90.
And I'm glad you talked about textbooks.
My question to you is about archiving.
I go back and look at Gil Strang's book, 18.06,
or Sussman 6.001 all the time, and I've been
out and out for a long time.
How is it that OCW after so many learns or
perhaps MITx, in ten years, in twenty years,
can go back and refresh the material that
they learned?
That's my question.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Well, of course, what
I said to an earlier question, MITx or something
like it, is open education, which means it's
going to be--.
The content is going to be available to anyone
who wants to--.
>>MALE #9: Yeah, but this content will vary
and grow over this period of time.
And when it's flat, like a PDF, you can print
it out and put it in your file.
But when it's more interactive, that's hard
to capture.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Yeah.
Yeah.
So, that is something about OCW.
Much of OCW is PDF.
I don't know exactly what is being planned
as far as that's concerned for MITx.
It is our hope that it would be interactive
in a way that would be more up to date on
a given basis.
But that's still to be worked out.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: It's an interesting
question.
With OCW, we have worked out ways of archiving
stuff.
So, we archive to what's called D-space at
MIT.
It's a big repository.
You can get to all the old OCW stuff from
2001 in there.
How you do that on an interactive system?
Good question.
I don't think we know yet.
[laughs]
>>MALE #9: Thank you very much.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Thank you.
>>MALE #10: Hi.
Adam Bookbinder.
I work here.
Speaking of textbooks, back in I think 2003,
2004, I was a grad student and I first heard
of OpenCourseWare and I was very excited to
hear about this.
And I remember finding that only a few of
the courses had textbooks and that's still
the case that it's only a few of them.
As you said, the cost of textbooks is incredibly
high, especially for people in community colleges
and so forth.
And given that the people at MIT are some
of the elites in their fields, you could set
standards for textbooks and so forth.
And I guess I'm wondering how hard is it to
get a standard textbook released openly and
get it used widely?
That could help out a lot of even traditional
students with school if they didn't have to
each go through the whole textbook rigmarole
if there were a free and open textbook, especially
for basic subjects.
I mean, linear algebra hasn't really changed
in 50 years, you know?
[laughter]
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Yeah.
I mean, the answer to that varies from publisher
to publisher.
A lot of these textbooks are locked up with
publishers.
And we had a case recently where a faculty
member went back to the publisher and said,
"Hey, I think it's time for you to give me
back the rights to my book.
I wanna put it on OpenCourseWare."
And that happened.
But if it's a book that's being actively used,
the publishers aren't gonna do that.
On the other hand, we have something called
"OCW Scholar Courses."
We're building 20 foundation level courses--first-year
courses in math, physics, biology, computer
science.
And what we're trying to do there is exactly
deal with this issue.
We're trying to get enough notes and stuff
together that effectively we have what the
textbook would have.
So, we've got five of those on OCW now.
We have another seven coming in the next three
weeks.
And by the end of next year, we'll have a
total of 20.
So, those will address for the foundation
level, I think, the content issues.
Are you signaling to me, Graham?
>>Graham Wharton: I'm your clock.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: We can probably take
a couple of more questions and then we, I
think, have to call a halt.
This is a one--.
And thank you so much.
This is great.
You guys are fantastic.
>>FEMALE #3: Hi.
I was wondering if you could say anything
about what sort of content MITx is gonna offer
and whether it's gonna be digitized versions
of current MIT classes or whether there's
gonna be new content?
And also, what sort of time commitment?
Is it gonna be similar to the Stanford model
in that it's a scaled down version of a college
class?
So, to make it more accessible to working
people and people who are in school doing
other things.
That sort of thing.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: It's easy to answer
that.
Stay tuned.
>>FEMALE #3: OK.
[giggles]
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: We're not involved
in the design of those courses and I think
those decisions are being made right now.
So, we'll see.
Stanford has been a good model.
Whether MIT chooses to follow that or not,
it remains to be seen.
>>FEMALE #3: All right.
Thanks.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Thanks for your question.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: I should add that the
director of C-Suite, who is lead on MITx,
has offered to talk about this at Google Cambridge.
>>MALE A #11: What is the role of a textbook
publisher going forward?
And what do you think of Apple's textbook
initiative?
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Oh, I don't know if
I--.
I don't know if we have time to get into that.
And I'm not really necessarily an expert in
that.
You know, I think there's a lot of different
opinions at this point in time.
It's exciting from a technology perspective.
It's a lot of whiz bang.
I mean, these textbooks are unbelievable.
But they're not open.
And we're in the open world.
>>MALE #11: Thank you.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: One more?
>>MALE #12: Thank you for one last question.
I'm a high school educator, so I noted with
interest that the high school market is something
that you guys target as a potential future
partner.
So, I really have two things I'm curious about.
One is, do you see anybody currently now doing
for high school what OCW has done for college-level
study?
And two, what do you think high school partnership
is going to look like for OCW?
Do you have ideas what that might look like?
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: So, we have a cycle, high
school update for high school--.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Highlights for high
school.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Yeah.
Where we've created a portal for high school
teachers and students to come in.
We did not change the content, but to point
out where in the present OCW content things
are useful for high school, particularly AP
classes.
So, we have that.
Take a look.
There are many of us who do take our content,
which we created for MIT, and we take it to
high school.
So for example, I have a course that I teach
with a colleague of mine, history, on Asian
History, and we use a lot of visuals.
And we've taken this to high schools.
And we've actually trained close to two thousand
high school teachers in face-to-face workshops
using our OCW site for it to be used in high
school classes.
>>MALE #12: Thank you.
>>Graham Wharton: So, I want to thank both
of you very much for coming and sharing all
of this with us.
This is very exciting.
I think Scott has a few words to say about
upcoming events.
And I invite you all to stay around a little
bit after his words to chat with everyone
and to enjoy the remainder of the food.
>>Shigeru Miyagawa: Thank you.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Thanks.
>>Scott Morrison: First, I want to thank--.
>>Graham Wharton: And once again, please join
me in a round of applause.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Thank you.
[applause]
>>Scott Morrison: OK.
Just very quickly before the networking and
the remainder of the food, I just want to
let you know about a couple of upcoming MIT
Club of New York events.
We have a social event next week.
It's an interclub Winter Mingle on February
7th.
February 27th, Energy Efficiency and Quantum
dot Nano Materials.
March 1st, another event that was being put
together by Yu-Hui Lin, who is our Vice President
of Educational and Cultural Programs who is
responsible, her and her team, responsible
from the club for tonight's event.
It'll be MIT Comes to New York, an evening
with Professor Peter Diamond.
He's an institute professor, Nobel Laureate
in Economics and the discussion will be on
significant global economic issues of the
day.
So, we hope that you'll join us for that.
That will be held at Credit Swiss.
And again, that's on March 1st.
March 6th, MIT Public Service Center is the
PSC, another wonderful innovation-led group
doing work all around the world.
This will be MIT Club of New York Professional
Programs and the Hub New York City presenting
New York City's second annual launch of the
MIT Idea's Global Challenge.
So, again, that's March 6th.
March 17th, our community services will be
asking for volunteers for the 2012 First Robotics
Competition, New York Regional Championship
at the Javits Center.
Again, March 17th.
And then, March 27th, something that I think
will be of interest.
Professional Programs presenting on Speaking
Up.
This will be a panel discussion about how
managers in varied industries will discuss
how they communicate effectively, and in some
cases, cross-culturally.
And then, the last one to mention is May 15th,
the Energy C-Suite Series on electron beam
technology.
So, we do hope that you'll join us and please
join us now for networking and food.
Thanks very much.
>>Cecilia D’Oliveira: Great.
[applause]